on the hill tonight for the giants will
be alex wood
the 30 year old left-hander an
eight-year veteran that's what he's done
it since starts five and three with a
three seven nine era
there's another ground ball that's
tapped in third charged by bossler and
[Applause]
sunshine plenty of room inning over
one man left on wade yaskremsky solano
coming up
and your d back starting pitcher tonight
rookie right-hander matt peacock back
after leaving his start in oakland last
week
after he took that comebacker off his
pitching hand
that is grabbed out there beautifully
in the dirt no crawford beats it out
rojas and an outstanding play on kind of
an in-between hop
there goes crawford and it's ball four
to belly just off the inside
and the bases are loaded
out the ground ball hits it right to
nick ahmed
and peacock walks a high wire but it
puts a zero on the board
no score in san francisco
into the hole i may get a glove on it
but no more and that's a base hit for
casalli
that ball is smoke and over the head
of lo castro
it's a double for vossler cassani the
third
man did he clobber that ball
[Applause]
lined a rocket to first walk or a play
at second
and they picked vosler off the bag
[Applause]
that was an absolute missile down to
first base and christian walker turns
the double play and gets peacock out of
trouble
[Applause]
right center field that is in there
to the seventh archway solano
will stop at second with a double as the
relay comes in
there's that rice airfield gap we're
talking about regards to solano
two down as solano takes third
and that's a two out money hit into the
right field corner into the first
archway
solano is scored and belt will ease into
second with a stand-up double
and the giants are on the board one
nothing and there's life in that dugout
and kelly fly out his first time carson
gets a hold of one and hits it deep to
center
and that's gonna get to the wall
walker's on the move
christian walker coming around third no
throw from crawford
and carson kelly ties it at one
three two cassalli slow roller guess
what kurt casale is gonna be two for two
he's owed a few of those that one gets
by
walker so lava waves got a hit
casale has to hold
[Applause]
he hit it harder last time but it was
picked by the first base but this time
he got it through
there they go 3-2 is just a little
chopper to first
walker to peacock for out number three
well the giants threaten again but again
they do not score so it's still
one to one
[Music]
as it is donovan solano's got his second
hit
that one's going to kick against the
sidewall and he's going to test the
castro
the throw and it's offline so solano is
in scoring position it's his second
double of the game and here's crawford
who swings and it's a high drive
into deep left center field way back
there still going
and oreos
it's a two run opposite field homer
to deep left center field by brandon
crawford
301 giants the 15th home run of the year
for crawford now a swing belt lines one
over the head of the leaping walker at
first base it toward the corner now belt
is going to try for two he's testing the
arm
of lo castro and the throw from lo
castro for the right field corner is
offline again
and belt slides in safely with a double
didn't get the call from tom hallian
that time and it's two and two
arson smokes one high in the air deep to
left
hand carson
kelly looking real hitterish that's his
eighth and it's a 3-2 ball game
here's a liner in the left face it
that's one of the best swings in a long
time for kurt casalli
and it's his third hit of the game
number park is on it
and that's the third out in the seventh
inning to the eighth we go
escobar will lead it off down three to
eleven two four they trail it three two
that one's in the rye to base it for
walker
christian aboard for the second time
tonight
and digs that one throw it's by boss
learn into left
walker has to hustle back to the bag at
second
[Music]
now a chance for babin smith two on and
one out
so here is pavon smith and he's been the
hottest of all the d-back setters
belt's got it to crawford one to rogers
two
a double play ending over
just like that the d-backs with a threat
and on the next pitch
inning over three to two giants
[Applause]
past the mound up the middle base headed
to center field
man did he need that he needed it as
sort of the giants a lead off hitter
with speed
slater trying to get the run home
against that man stefan crakey
big run big run at third base
giants leading by just the one run base
hit to right field slater
gets it done duggar scores
four to two giants and two guys have
been struggling lately
both get hits in this end buster posey
likes what he's saying
that boat is crushed high and deep
center field
marte squaring up under it right at the
edge of the track
both runners will tag up in advance
slater scores
yaz the third and crawford gets his
third rbi of the game
and everybody's standing at oracle park
now with two down
and two strikes strike three
caught on the inside corner the giants
are back home
and they come home and take game one
from the d backs
five to two